[Music]
you
the gallbladder is a pear-shaped pouch
underneath your liver with the liver it
attaches to the small intestine through
a series of tubes called
ducts bile a substance made by the liver
to break down fat is stored in the
gallbladder
when fatty food from a meal reaches the
small intestine the gallbladder releases
bile into it to help digest the fat
cholecystectomy is a surgical procedure
to remove the gallbladder it is usually
done when there is evidence of
gallbladder disease such as gall stones
or polyps it is also done for a biliary
dyskinesia which is a condition where
the gallbladder doesn't work properly
laparoscopic cholecystectomy requires
only small keyhole incisions through the
abdomen known as ports to reach the
gallbladder the surgeon will insert
tubes called trocars through these ports
one port is usually located at the navel
or umbilicus carbon dioxide gas pumped
through the umbilical port will inflate
the abdomen so its contents can be
viewed more easily next your surgeon
will insert the laparoscope through the
umbilical port images from its camera
will be transmitted to a video monitor
in the operating room using instruments
passed through other ports your surgeon
will grasp the gallbladder clip off its
main artery and duct
drop it into a specimen bag and remove
it through one of the ports after the
laparoscope is removed a port valve will
be left in place briefly to allow all of
the carbon dioxide to escape from the
abdomen the incisions will be closed
with sutures
followed by skin glue or skin closure
tape
if there are complications with your
laparoscopic procedure your surgeon will
switch to an open procedure with a
larger incision